hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich mache heute ein leckeres rezept
es gibt nämlich bratapfel zimtschnecken
das ist so ein rezept das habe ich
gestern spontan gemacht und habe auf
instagram ein bild hochgeladen und was
euch also gut gefallen hat habe ich
gedacht komm das filmen war jetzt weil
jetzt auch gerade noch die apfelsaison
ist und bestimmt jeder von euch ganz
viele äpfel zu hause hat und ich zeige
euch jetzt erst mal ganz kurz die
zutaten für den hefeteig und spätere
leben für die füllung ich frau für den
hefeteig 500 gramm mehl 80 gramm zucker
einen teelöffel salz ein würfel hefe 80
gramm butter die habe ich jetzt schon
ein bisschen erwärmt dass sie eben
flüssig wird zwei bis drei esslöffel
wasser und etwa 200 milliliter und die
äpfel gibt es später das ist jetzt mode
dekoration
jetzt will ich zuerst das wasser und die
hilfe und brösel die hefe bleibt rein
wieso die heg ins wasser weil im wasser
kein fett drin ist und dann geht eben
die hefe später besser auf deswegen löse
ich dir jetzt darin ein bisschen auf und
gibt gleich noch zucker mit dazu und
dann haben wir später richtig schönen
hefeteig
und jetzt kommt die hefe mit dem wasser
einfach direkt in meine rührschüssel ich
würde es jetzt mit der kitchenaid ihr
könnt aber natürlich auch den teig mit
der hand verkneten das geht auch müsse
eben ein bisschen länger kneten salt
kommt der zug dann das lasse ich mir ja
immer so ein bisschen was übrig kann ich
nämlich später noch schauen ob ich noch
mehr braucht oder nicht
jetzt noch st und etwa 150 milliliter
milch da schauen wir dann auch gleich ob
er alles brauchen oder nicht
jetzt lasse ich einfach mal den teig
kneten und wenn ein bisschen verknetet
ist kommt dann die mutter gleich mit
dazu
der teig ist jetzt durchgeknetet ich
habe jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr mail
genommen weil ich einfach ein sehr
großes ei hatte und dann müsste dann
einfach schauen
je nachdem wie groß ebene sei es mit ein
bisserl mehr benutzen
und jetzt ist das schön weich aber nicht
mehr klebrig naja jetzt eine kugel drauf
das sieht auch das ist ein richtig
schöner götter teig und jetzt gebe ich
den in die schüssel wieder zurück mit
etwas mühe gibt auch mehr drüber
und dann wird der teig abgedeckt und
darf jetzt so etwa eine halbe stunde auf
gehen und in der zwischenzeit kann ich
jetzt schon mal die füllung vorbereiten
für die füllung brauche ich 70 g weiche
butter
ich brauche dem zucker und nehmen dafür
vier esslöffel zucker und zwei teelöffel
zimt und für die äpfel ich habe jetzt
hier sechs äpfel dann habe ich hier drei
esslöffel zucker zwei teelöffel zimt und
ich brauche den saft einer halben
zitrone und jetzt fange ich auch direkt
mit den äpfeln an
am besten nehmen dir da welche die so
ein bisschen säuerlich sind zum beispiel
boskoop oder elster und die werden jetzt
geschält ich mag es eigentlich wenn mal
erzählt weil ich finde dass inhalt die
meisten vitamine mit drinnen die
ballaststoffe
aber ihr könnt die apfel schadens euch
benutzen ohne apfel täter rauskaufen das
mach ich nämlich gleich man muss das ja
nicht wegschmeißen oder ist einfach so
auf aber in der füllung würden die mich
jetzt so ein bisschen stören weil sie
dann ein bisserl hart bleiben
das kerngehäuse habe ich jetzt auch
schon rausgeholt und jetzt werde ich die
äpfel in kleine würfel schneiden muss
manches einfach hier im alligator da
gibt's am schnellsten und ich aber
gleichmäßige wird
die apfelstücke gebe ich jetzt direkt in
einen topf
das sollte nicht zu klein sein da kommt
jetzt der zitronensaft mit rein
und auch die drei esslöffel zucker mit
dem zimt jetzt könnt ihr den herd
einstellen und das ganze eben so lange
kochen bis die äpfel ein bisschen weich
sind
das heißt so etwa zehn minuten ich
schaue jetzt erst mal auf höchster stufe
und anschaulich auf mittlerer hitze
runde
der hefeteig ist aufgegangen und jetzt
kann ich ihnen auch bereits aus holz
und zwar wird er jetzt eckig ausgerollt
und von den maßen hessen ist so etwa 40
mal 60
da streiche ich jetzt die weiche butter
drauf
dann kommt da das im zucker drüber
ein bisschen zucker lasse ich jetzt
übrig das sträucher noch mal auf die
oberfläche und jetzt verteile ich auf
dem zucker noch die getragenen
apfelstücke
jetzt kann ich bereits den teig
ausrollen und hier unten am rand habe
ich übrigens so etwa 23 zentimeter frei
gelassen
das sind jetzt keine apfelstücke damit
sie gleich nicht so ausführen
jetzt kommt die rolle auf ein holzbrett
denn ich muss ja gleich schneiden dann
legt das so gleichmäßig wie möglich hin
damit sie ungefähr gleich dick ist
und jetzt eilig sie in 16 stücke dafür
halbiere ich sie einmal und dann wird
jede hälfte in acht stücke geteilt und
es geht einfach indem ihr das immer
wieder halbiert
und jetzt habe ich hier so eine kraft
die backform also nicht in vielen
löchern so eine eckige und da setze ich
die jetzt rein da kommt aber vorher noch
eine back folie rein oder ein backpapier
die bak wolle die kammer hat mehrmals
benutzen muss sie nicht danach
wegschmeißen und jetzt kommuniziert die
schönen film stecken
jetzt stehe ich noch ein bisschen zucker
auf die oberfläche und dann kommen die
zimtschnecken in den kalten backofen und
zwar stelle ich den dann gleich auf 180
grad ober und unterhitze ein und
entweder stellen sie den jetzt wie ich
dann den kalten ofen dann gehen sie dann
noch mal mit der wärme auf oder entdeckt
sie jetzt mit folie ab und lass dir so
nochmal aufgehen und stellte dann den
heißen ofen aber dass jetzt ein bisschen
schneller geht stelle ich sie eben den
kalten ofen und dann heizt er hoch und
die gehen hat noch mal bissel auf und da
packen die dann für ungefähr 30 bis 35
minuten bis die oberfläche und die
unterseite schön goldbraun sind uns
liegt jetzt schon gut und ihr könnt euch
nicht vorstellen dass lechner am
bankenriesen mit
die bratapfel zimtschnecken sie nicht
gebacken und es riecht hier wirklich
schon richtig lecker weihnachtlich
winterliche und ich habe sie so etwa
fünf bis zehn minuten abkühlen lassen
und jetzt kommt da noch eine klasse
obendrauf
hier können sie zwar ist auch so lassen
die schmecken so schon richtig gut der
hefeteig ist richtig schön locker
aufgegangen dass zimt zucker her ist so
ein bisschen an der oberfläche
karamellisiert und die abrüstung ist und
schön weich aber trotzdem so leicht
bissfest doch und vor allem bringen die
eben diese saftigkeit das ist wirklich
super saftig und ich finds halt ganz
lecker wenn da noch eine klasse oben
drauf kommt deswegen zeige ich euch da
kurz die vier zutaten
ich habe hier frischkäse und zwar zwei
esslöffel als zwei große esslöffel dann
puderzucker dem tier nach geschmack ich
nehme etwa drei bis vier esslöffel etwas
zitronensaft vor ungefähr einer halben
zitrone und viel vanille extrakt denn es
soll eine wann die lecker so werden
nämlich einfach direkt hier den
frischkäse da kommt betonen saft rein
das passt hervorragend zu dazu das ist
halt so ein bisschen säuerlich trotzdem
süß und daneben durch das vanille aroma
also wirklich sehr lecker
da am besten ein schneebesen und
verrührt es kurz
dann kommt auch direkt potter zu können
jetzt ist so lange bis die klümpchen von
frischkäse wechseln
es kommt noch vanille extrakt mit rein
oder empfehle ich euch auch bei den
exakt zu nehmen weil es einfach
wunderbar war nämlich schmeckt weil er
einfach konzentriert ist
da geb ich schon so guten halben
teelöffel bis teelöffel rhein zum
richtig stark nach man in der schmecken
ansonsten könnte auch eine vanilleschote
nehmen unter das mag auskratzen und von
der konsistenz her ist der kurs nicht
flüssig aber auch nicht ganz dick aber
eben schön streichfähig und ich trage
jetzt mit einem pinsel direkt auf diesem
schlitten auf grad ganz grob das muss
mich komplett bedeckt sein
jetzt können die zecken auch schon
probiert werden hier jetzt mal einen
raus euch mal ein bisschen hoch die
werden und wie locker die auch sind und
ich mache mal auf für euch und das
blättert haben auch richtig schön auf
ein bisschen butter drin haben und die
äpfel mit drin haben und das ist
wirklich total lecker
genau wie ich gesagt wenn ihr das rezept
gerne nachmachen wollt dann geht einfach
auf meinem blog auf cds - blog.de
natürlich könnt ihr da jetzt auch den
zimt weglassen oder mit dazu machen oder
gerne auch noch andere gewürze mit
reinnehmen kernstadt äpfel birnen nehmen
als ihr könnt es auch gerne abwandeln
oder zum beispiel auch ein paar mandeln
in der pfanne etwas bräunen und die noch
mit rein geben dann habt ihr sogar noch
in kranj mit drin also die ideen gehen
einem da nicht aus gerne könnt ihr mir
schreiben die erste abgewandelt habt
oder wenn ihr sie packt dann schickt mir
gerne ein foto auf facebook oder auf
instagram und es schaue ich mir dann
dort gerne an
und ja ich würde sagen ich verteile die
jetzt ein bisschen an die nachbarschaft
denn es sind ziemlich viele und murat
kommt sowieso gleichheit mein bruder
kommt noch gleich und die freuen sich
dann wenn es auch noch ein paar bekommen
also viel spaß beim abpacken und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder biss
dann schwingt mit dreckigen händen